hello we begin with breaking news from
the Netherlands a court in Amsterdam has
convicted three men of murder for the
Downing of flight Malaysia Airlines
mh-17 in 2014. the passenger jet was
flying from Amsterdam to Kuala Lumpur
when it was shot down over eastern
Ukraine all 298 people on board were
killed the convicted are two Russian
Former Intelligence Officers and a
Ukrainian separatist leader a fourth
person was acquitted
on the 17th of July 2014 the injured
parties were suddenly faced with the
death of one or more of their loved ones
as a result of the mh-17 crash this is
incredibly hard for the injured parties
that they must live with the ongoing
uncertainty of what must have happened
in the last moments of the aircraft and
to what extent the relatives and loved
ones were aware of their fate let's talk
to Steph fast and she's joining us from
skipol airport in the Netherlands so
tell us more about how this verdict was
reached
well the judge said he had no doubt
there was no doubt from the court that
what the investigators and also the
prosecutors have found years of research
and investigations that a book missile
was fired from a separatist area in
eastern Ukraine and hit the mh-17 plane
killing everyone on board the defense
had argued during the trial that there
were different scenarios possible but
the judges decided there was only one
scenario and that's what happened the
four Suspects on trial one of them has
now been found not guilty because his
role in the transport of this book
missile could not be proven but the
three others according to the church
were heavily involved they were
responsible for the logistics of
transporting this book from Russia to
Eastern Ukraine the judge said we have
no evidence of who actually fired the
book but the fact that they brought it
there a Lethal Weapon they accepted the
consequences had a plane a civilian
plane even could be hit so the response
here by the relatives there were
hundreds of relatives attending the
verdict some of them came from Australia
a group of 60 because most of the
victims were Dutch but also others came
from 16 countries around the world well
there is a great relief and I'm now
joined by one of the relatives Robert
Van Heinen he lost three relatives one
of one of them was his brother his
sister-in-law and their child so you
have been listening to this quite
emotional verdict especially the judge
was pointing out how no respect was
shown by the suspect so how did you
experience this verdict I'm very glad
that the judges made this verdict and
I'm very glad that after eight years
after after eight long years finally
judge decides that there was a fake
information involved and that what
public attorney stated is right and I'm
very glad there's that three of the four
suspects are heavily punished for this
but the suspects are not here they have
not attended the trial there's very
little chance they will ever serve this
life sentence how does that make you
feel it it doesn't change my feelings
because I knew from the start that the
suspects
there's very little chance that the
search space be uh came after bars a bit
after
it's very very important that the
Justice decided what has it has been
done that it's right and it's very
important for me that the judge has
pointed those subjects as really now
convicted people the church also pointed
out that great suffering this has caused
to the relatives because the plane was
shut down the body scattered over a
field has been they've been lying there
for a long time it must have been a
really really hard time for you yes it's
it's very really hard time and these
memories come back and we also had our
relatives our beloved in Parts brought
back we had several funerals about it
but this is very sad it's very hard to
reveal to do to yeah to refer to to
very hard and set to where they can but
on the other hand
I really appreciate it as well that the
judges
took the local people including in
suffering what they had had at a scene
ukrainians on the ground the Ukraine is
on the ground because we asked the
churches please pay attention to it we
wrote a letter to the major there and
I'm very glad that the judges in their
verdict remembered the local population
do you now feel justice has served and
can you have some kind of closure yes
juices have served very well but it's
not closing time because an appeal is
possible and an appeal I think it will
be
so it's not closing beside that there
are two other
other major
major points
the European the the basis for the
Europe European court and OCTA so it's
not close at all no so there will still
be more court cases I should say one of
them is in Strasbourg thank you so much
for joining us here live on Al Jazeera
so yeah we have to still hear from the
lawyers of the suspects if they will
appeal but what we know is of course
that the one suspect he was represented
by a lawyer has now found been found not
guilty so the three others that have
been convicted have not been presented
by lawyers so we have to wait and see
how that's going to develop and if there
will be an appeal okay thank you so much
stop us and Reporting from skipple
airport thank you